do you enjoy sipping drinks through
plastic straws
well if activists get their way you
won't be allowed to anymore these must
be banned they say why 500 million
plastic straws are used in this country
every single day and many end up in the
ocean polluting water and killing sea
life when celebrities speak politicians
listen Seattle recently banned straws
and other places want to do the same
straw suck and we are no longer going to
allow for plastic straws here in San
Francisco their time has come and gone
the idea that you're gonna ban straws
and save the world is ridiculous
Angela logo masini studies environmental
issues at the Competitive Enterprise
Institute
what will banning plastic straws
accomplish probably nothing at all it
might make some people in Hollywood feel
good it may make some politicians feel
good like they're doing something might
sound good at parties but it's not gonna
solve any problems plastic pollution in
the ocean is a real problem but only
about 1% of it comes from the United
States of that 1% a tiny amount comes
from plastic straws but what about that
500 million number in the USA alone over
500 million straws are being used every
single day most of which are going into
our oceans Americans toss out 500
million straws each day an incredible
500 million plastic straws where do they
all get that number every piece of
plastic they got it from this child
school project he says he got the 500
million straws a day figure through a
phone survey he conducted with straw
manufacturers I study the project to
reduce the number of straws the media
just accepts his 500 million number but
the actual number is much lower
according to the analysis firm techno me
okay so activists and media exaggerate
the problem 500 million 500 million 500
million still they promised it would be
easy to get rid of the straws if we can
reduce something that is easy that is
polluting to the environment that gets
stuck in turtles noses and causes damage
to the environment
let's do that progressive talk show host
ethan Behrman sometimes we do need a
little gentle guiding hand from
government governments gentle guiding
hand will either ban straws or order us
to replace this cheap plastic straw with
ones like these made of paper or bamboo
plastic doesn't actually biodegrade so
unlike a lot of other things paper for
example actually breaks down into other
components that's not a good thing
that means paper straws break down even
while you're using them they get soggy
they leak that's the beauty of plastic
it's enduring paper straws gonna break
down while you're drinking with it paper
and bamboo straws aren't environmentally
pristine either paper products take more
energy and more effort to produce you're
gonna have a net negative environmental
impact the paper doesn't degree in a
landfill either everything is
essentially mummified you're replacing a
superior product with an inferior one
and you're asking people to pay more for
it doesn't make a lot of sense it
doesn't and the higher price is the
final result paper straws are eight
times more expensive to make than
plastic straws won't this hurt
businesses I don't think so
maybe people won't use straws if it's a
dollar 79 to get the fountain drink at
Joe's corner deli that we're talking
about and now it's a dollar eighty three
I don't see that as being a huge
difference in the present this is what
environment will say about every policy
they put out a few cents here a few
cents there eventually begins to be a
burden
we don't need straws you know a lot of
things in life are not necessary but
beneficial and enjoyable banning straws
isn't gonna do anything for the
environment so what they're just trying
to do is take away my freedom for
nothing in return as the environment has
become cleaner that's become a specialty
of the environmental movement spend your
money on feel-good policies that make no
real difference I will stop stuck I will
stop sucking we'll all stop sucking